foreign
so
well what's up everybody uh glad to be
back this week
so what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be working with
open file that kind of came up last week
hey there jan how are you doing i'm glad
to see everybody glad
everybody's back today all right so
the reason why this shopping list
exercise is
a good one is it takes into account
a lot of different aspects
so let's just go ahead and get into it
because we got our file object we got a
plan we got a
air handle we have to learn a little bit
more about
files and a couple other things
i'm doing pretty good i don't know if
you've heard my voice i had a
with all this mask wearing i've realized
that i'm having
to yell a lot more so i'm gonna try to
hang in there
as long as we can we'll get at least
through the shopping list i promise you
that
and uh we'll see how i'm doing after
that but i tried to rest my voice
yesterday
and uh did not do a lot of recovering so
let's just go ahead and jump into it so
we got we got a
we got a ton of people here right now so
let's just get after it so
file and file object and open and things
like that
so let's learn about open first
so if you guys are new here
i am sam from python basics and
being afforded the wonderful opportunity
to
live stream with you guys on tuesdays so
this is
i told myself i would look and make sure
i think this is the seventh
stream it it may be the eighth
actually you know what i'll click over
to the playlist and beau has done an
awesome job bo
and quincy and i appreciate the
opportunity to get to be here
here let's go ahead and look uh today is
the seventh
today is the seventh live stream so we
did four took a week off and then are
back
so yes this is our fourth one and they
have all of them in their own playlist
so
uh in just a little bit of a history if
you are just joining us
these are a conglomerate of all
of the i don't think i've left the first
hundred
videos that i have on my channel so if
there's ever something that you saw here
and you don't wanna
and you may have a hard time going to
find it you can go back and search it
it's
my channel is down in the description
below but all right
open all right so this is how you handle
a file so we're going to go through this
because because
th this can get blurry really really
quickly
so i think we've talked about what these
are
these are so here i'll show you
if it has an equal sign in the function
it's an optional argument
also default argument so it's already
assigned
to a certain parameter mode
r is for read so by default
it is going to read the file
and you'll just see and we'll just jump
into it
so let's uh shoot i think i already
created that so we will do
um i think i have that in here too
so we're going to make this f so it does
not mess with our head about
this argument right here file
so we're going to do open
then i know this isn't here
test underscore
1 then txt
txt now
here let's just let's just leave this so
we're going to run this
we're going to go through everything all
right
so it fails right now
because
it defaults to r and r is going to read
the file
so if the file doesn't exist it can't
read it
so that's why if we want to create a
file and write to it
or create a brand new file we need to
make sure we do
w for write to open
and we're going to start dealing with
this so now
we bring this in we have no error so now
let's look at what
we can do with file
ah here we go
this is a lot of methods
and attributes so let's pull up
help on file this is centered right okay
you guys can see this
now here's a file input output text
input output wrapper
file object and
here are all of the methods
that we have excuse me
sorry guys now we've touched on this
before
where you can have a mix of
methods and arguments mixed in
so always go down here
and the ones that jump
out these are
these are the attributes so we're gonna
we're gonna look at this
so this is all we've done so far and
we're going to deal with this so right
now the file is open
and i can confirm this by
file closed and i don't have to pass it
parentheses because it's not a method
because it is sitting right here closed
so is the file closed
no false so right now now i'm going to
go
file close now i call file closed
is it closed yes it's true so this is
one of the things
that is very important
when you're managing files once you open
them
do whatever you want to with them then
make sure you close them
same thing with databases but we'll deal
with that at a later time all right
that might be a very good idea with the
with the honey and lemon yes
uh that thank you that is a very good
that is a very good point so all right
now so now i'm writing here so we're
going to open this up
so before i still have my file object
and dur on
file helps if you get your parentheses
going the right way
we have write so
help file
right okay
write string to stream
stream what is what is the stream
it's basically the stream of information
that is either going in
or coming out from your from your object
so if i were to let's leave this back
let's get rid of this open this back up
and then i go file dot
right and i just pass in the text
and write string
hello
oh well here's something interesting
what is this well this is the length of
the
stream that i just put in and we're
going to jump into this and we're going
to see
where all this goes so now
we need to close this so we have file
close
what was the name of our file
and let's see where did i put this this
is right here
so i have hello right here in my text
file well that's kind of cool
so now
now let's do this and i want to show you
because there's a problem um
actually why don't we look at reading it
so we comment this out
got file dot open
dot i guess i could have just
nope you know what we're not doing
anymore except under extreme situations
will we
will we copy so now i don't have to do
anything because it defaults to read
right
okay so now i have my file object and
what can i can i read
can i read my f can i read
let's see if i can do my alphabet really
really fast read
okay after i
read hello
okay well that's kind of cool let's get
this closed
f close
um all right f dot
right
hi how are
you now this is going to cause a problem
and let's see if anybody has seen or
experienced this f dot
close
all right so we're opening it we're
writing to it
then let's f dot
open
i already have a problem
not right
test underscore 1
text then
print f.read
all right so let's see we open it we
write to it we close it we open it we
read it
we close it all right
wait a second so we got a problem
where'd our hello go right so this is a
problem with
w it will overwrite the entire file
so basically it is it just opens it and
goes ahead and writes
wherever it starts and we're gonna learn
how to look at that
see it check it and work around it
so that's just one mode or two we just
looked at two
r and uh w
but let's get over here
uh do no there
all right so let's get with uh help
help dot
open so how in the world can we solve
this
because there's got to be there's got to
be a way around this
and there is don't don't don't so
all right
every time w is utilized it goes to the
top
and just starts now
a and we know you know we know about
appending with our use of
list so a opens it up
and goes to the end of the file and then
begins writing
so that's that's what we're going to be
utilizing for
our for for our shopping list
so let's go ahead and get started on
that so my
def my list
we're just going to open it and we're
going to go from there and we already
know
that we need to use
oh oh before we get before we get into
this
so let's look
pass
this is what's this is this is really
cool
so all right we have this open and
closed and you have to remember and
don't forget and it's super important
right
well guess what python has taken care
of this for us with a context manager
and it is literally this easy and this
simple
so with with
open so use open
what is your file test
one dot txt
then we are
writing to it
actually let's just read it right now
oh and i forgot as
f then f
print f dot
read so this context manager
handles all of this for you so you're
aliasing this so here's your file object
you're going to turn it into this so
this is basically the same as
this line right here and then also
whenever you get
done with this
go ahead and close it out for us
so boom there we are right there so this
is the
this is one of the things that is very
handy and you
need to get comfortable with this and
we're going to build upon it and we'll
go from there
but to just understand what it does for
now
so you can build upon it and uh because
you
this this is also a wonderful tool and
best practice
for working with databases so all right
you don't need that anymore so let's get
this in here so
uh let's get this let's get this file up
and running
so right now let's just let's just
figure out how to write to it
so width and we're going to call this
our shopping list
so with uh and we also learned that
we're going to be using
a we're going to append to it because
every time we open this we're going to
we're going to want to add to it
i just add to it but later we're going
to want to be able to delete things but
right now
we're we'll deal with that we'll deal
with that soon enough
so open then
shopping list dot txt
and i said we were going to use a for
append
as f actually let's just do file because
apparently i have that and i don't want
to
make a ton of mistakes and drive you
guys nuts with the fixing of the typing
but i hope everybody has had a good week
and if we have anybody joining us right
now
what we are doing is we are going
through and we are
we are using the skills that we have so
far to date
to build us a shopping list and we're
sprinkling in some
uh context manager right here with our
with
then then we are going to
be learning how to delete and uh
learn how to work with our file object
and
then we need to air handle then we need
to
learn about two interesting um
methods associated with a file object
so all right first we need to
have something that tells something to
the
end user enter
item
nope we don't want this right now we're
going to do
item equals input
because we're taking input from the user
enter
item we're going to handle that issue
next so right now
all right so right now we're going to
take this item
and then we're going to add this add
this to our list right
so file
dot right
and then we're going to input item
wow all right
okay so let's see where we are have i
lost anybody everybody
good
okay oh i just saw you can't you can't
be at the office
okay
all right and i only have one kid on uh
azuma eating today so hopefully the um
the quality is a little bit better
all right so we have a built-in flaw
right now and we're gonna we're gonna
solve this but
i want you to understand the a uh the
append
and then we'll go from there so we got
my my
list all right
enter item
bread oh
hmm
all right let's run this again uh
milk well this
this is a little tedious
so let's just one check and see
here hang on a second i just realized
uh all right
let's do w first because i just realized
i had partial
of another item so let's get this spread
all right so now we need to change this
to a
because we'll see all right so milk
and then uh eggs we need to run this one
more time
and we're gonna see the problem that
we're solving we need to solve two
problems
eggs because i will tell you right now
the user will not uh
what are we doing right here the user
went will will not tolerate
having to call the the function
over and over and over and over again so
what tools and skills do we have at our
disposal right now
first how about we solve this problem
right here
so like i said
a the the append mode
it will just go to the append of the
file the
the end of the file and we'll look and
see how to handle this in a minute
and it will just continue on from there
so what skills do we have
in our back pocket to get this to go
down a line
okay solves problem
solves problem one okay
so let's get this going so let's check
and make sure we got bread
then let's run this again and then we
got milk
all right let's get this up
okay bingo ah
great question so
and this is what i love all right
so in python this
is a new line let's look at print
right here this is the new line this is
how python handles new line
it is line
and i will explain you know i looked at
escape characters
a little bit ago and i was like no you
know what i don't know if we'll get into
that
so now if i print new line
so python already defaults on print
at the end to go to a new line so i just
told python
to assign new line
to this so i'm printing
new line and python
is already putting a new line now while
we're here
let's just look at this this is tab
so python tabs over
python tat so you have your new line in
your tab and the reason why
this because this is an escape character
so this is how if you're doing something
and python needs to understand because
it had to differentiate between
in so it got assigned um
and how to handle and read this and
maybe we'll do a whole lesson on
uh escape characters
that might be something cool if i'm uh
if my voice hangs in there
so problem one
solved oops apparently i have a couple
of these open
all right problem one solved but now
we need to keep this open repeating
and checking for
while true
oops i can't even remember if it's
open or closed bracket
okay it's the closed bracket
so what i did is to put this in a loop
i moved everything over so now
my list will hopefully close it out
my list will stay open so we got uh
what do we have in our list what do we
have on our list
bread milk let's add let's add uh
eggs
eggs butter
oh shoot we don't have a way to get
out do we so caused
solved one problem caused another i love
it so now let's get out
restart show now let's see what that did
to our list
oh still there because it still wrote
and it was just sitting
so now we have to have a way to exit
so let's deal with this
all right so that always writes
so let's come up here so
if let me just keep this really really
easy if item equals
i doubt we'll need all caps
exit
then all right let me click back over
here i haven't seen
chat in a while how do we get
out of a loop anybody seen that yet i
can't remember if we've talked about it
so you guys
have to forgive me have we talked
anything
bingo break
and you have continue as well so if
you're coming from another language
if i were to want to go back
up to a certain spot especially like a
while loop
and not continue down i would just
continue back through my loop i would
use continue
but here oops
i want to break out of
this and jump out
and move on all right
let me check my notes here we go here we
go
so now i have my if
now i need my else
and boom
if else so all right so now let's check
this so we got
um we got bread
now we need uh jelly
and what else now we need uh some
lettuce
okay now i'm gonna exit all right
okay we've made we've made some pretty
good progress
we good so far everybody good
how are we going to read this
so right now i have this as append
i know that i could
put a put a read
you could do that you you could and
actually
uh however you'd like
if you'd like no no space entered
you you could completely uh do however
however you'd like it to exit you can
exit
if you don't want anything in the string
if you want to if you want an empty
string
that works too
so we need to learn how to solve
how to be able to read and write
at the same time and this is like the
coolest thing
well i think it's the coolest thing ever
let's get in help let's get capslock off
first help
open yes i know it's 122
lines
this is literally the neatest thing
plus so basically it's
this and the other so all i have to do
is come up here and add a plus sign
and now this is readable and writable
but we got a problem what you'll notice
is that every problem we solve
creates a new one and we have to deal
with it
so now i can read and write it
i can read and write to it but
where does this start
so if i want to read now i need to
figure out a way to read the file
so i'm going to throw in an lf here
but let's get out of here
now i want to show you the problem first
elif uh let's
let's do list so if i want if i if they
type in
list well we need to be consistent
sorry guys i just realized that i'm not
being consistent with my quotation marks
list
so then file
file dot
print file dot read
is that gonna be right because yeah
we're gonna have a
so we're gonna do this so let's and i
need to close that out
all right is this megan did i lose
anybody
exit thank you
all right
ah item caps lock off
item
so let's see how i do here all right
so right now
huh i got i got nothing
but i know let's close this i can't
remember
but i know there's something there right
okay i have everything there
and let's see if this is still working
um let's add uh
grapes my kids have been eating a lot of
grapes
all right so then exit
all right so we got we got a little bit
of a dilemma here
but it's actually quite simple and
elegant so there's two things we need to
learn about
is it file is it showing is it still
file
awesome okay so f
equals open dot
shopping list txt
all right der on f
seek and tell
so f dot seek
help f dot seek
okay cookie change stream position
ahaha okay zero start a stream
one current stream position offset by a
negative
and two end of stream offset by
unusual negative hmm
all right and what does tell do
help dot f dot tell
returns the current position
all right so
let's look at something l if
so actually
let's look at something right
here print
file dot tell right because it's going
to tell us where it is
and then
let's let's put it right here as well
print dot file dot tell
this all makes sense in a second
peanut butter
huh um potatoes
okay wait a second wait a second as i'm
moving through my file
my current position my current position
in the stream the stream of data going
into my file
is moving down the file so when i want
to read this
i'm at the end of the file there's
nothing to read
right so let's exit this so
we're gonna let's make sure we have this
closed
all right so now let's bring this open
so f equals f equals
open dot
shopping list shoppinglist.txt
already defaults to read right okay read
so then f dot tell
0 the beginning of the file
so then if i do file dot read
i have all of this so if i do print
file.i read
i do this on purpose so this already
read through this once
so it can't read through it again
because it's sitting down at the bottom
so now where's my tell
75 there's nothing more to read but
if i come up here and go file dot seek
what does seek do change my position
zero start of stream so if i reset this
to zero
okay then i go
now let's let's look at this for just a
second this is the actual string
with all of my new line characters
i printed it print understands newline
formats it very nicely so when we want
to read this
file we need to change the seek
we need to change the tell and we use
seek
to change tell make sense
everybody got that so if i do list
i need to go and do
so we're going to change this actually
let's comment it out so you can
go back and look at it so
file dot seek
back to the beginning save run
all right then list
boom there i am now i also don't need
this either so let's uh
let's go exit let's run this
list cool so i got
i got bread milk eggs butter jelly
lettuce grapes
peanut butter potatoes and let's add
a chicken one more and then let's exit
so cool now we're going to verify that
everything is
functioning and working very cool now
okay so we've done
we've done a lot of stuff here how's
everybody doing
with this this seemed to make sense
everybody like it
all right ew i think i need to refresh
this because it's showing and i'm not
seeing any chat
all right so
okay okay that that's everything all
right let's get that off here
now we've got to figure out a way to
delete
an item and this is where it gets
this is where it gets fun all right
so we've got to figure out a way
to remove any opportunities for people
to misspell so numbers are a perfect way
to do this
so we're going to i didn't even check my
mic
am i coming through loud and clear
i usually do that i was a little
frazzled today
uh of course right before the stream uh
my smoke
one of my smoke alarms was going off and
of course
my daughter was laughing because i
pulled it out from the ceiling
first i tried the battery then then i
did the uh
then it kept chirping then i unplugged
it
from this from the ceiling and it kept
chirping it was
a reference to one of her favorite
television shows and she was dying
laughing while i was running around
trying to get ready and she was supposed
to be on her zoom anyway too so
all right i digress but if you're just
joining us we are working in building a
shopping list
working with a file context manager
how to have a file opened readable and
editable because i don't even know is
that a word editable
able to edit able to read and edit at
the exact same time
and we are using utilizing the a plus
mode append with
plus so being able to do both
because a opens a file if it already
exists
and goes to the end of it and then now
we just learned
how to change the location of basically
our cursor
in the position of the stream the stream
of data
to then read the file so now the reason
why this works nice and neat
is it goes once you read it goes to the
end of the file you can continue editing
so let's just jump back to where we are
so
now now we have another dilemma
so what we need to do is
while in the midst of
and pull this over because we're going
to have lots of stuff right here
so i'm going to save you guys a little
bit of pain and i'll just show you
i'll give you give you a little a little
bit but
but not a lot so
we need to know how to
get rid of one so we need to wrap this
up and
what skills we have so far is we know
how to link
to display a number and a list so right
now
why don't we take our file throw it into
a throw it into a list
wrap it up and then um
enumerate with it so items
oops items equals list
a numeric
file.read now check this out this was so
cool
all right so then we want to split it
oops split
and how does split work anybody remember
everybody remember how split works
so that was the one is for enumerate
because people are not going to tolerate
you
we know zero indexing the end user
does not care they want to know item one
they're not going to go item zero why is
it on item zero so we're going to
enumerate we're gonna start at item one
all right let's see let's see let's see
all right so then now
oops i did not wrap list up so the
reason why we're wrapping this in list
is because you're you just created a
enumerator
object and then we want to put these
into a list
to build our tuples
all right we did touch on uh
enumerate i believe one time before oh i
think i saw a comment coming through
splits a string using the identifier uh
identifier you mean delimiter
because right now split is going to
split on the white space
any sort of any new line any tab any
space
so it's going to automatically go and
read read each
each item and split that out cool
i i misspeak
all the time i just i will always just
yes no you no you're you're absolutely
correct it will split on the delimiter
delimiter is a weird word i get it i
don't i don't blame anybody for not
choosing
uh the right word if if the whole
thought
process is correct it's the same thing
you know what you meant
no you're absolutely fine i knew what
you meant it's just uh
the how to identify where to split it i
knew what i knew exactly what you meant
i just wanted to make sure
i just wanted to make sure that uh we
were talking about the same thing no
that was great
so now we got to get this out printed
then take more input from the user to
get it out of the list
and then be able to ensure
where the placement is because this gets
this gets fun
pretty quickly so now
now we need to look and get this printed
much much more
neatly so count so we're going to split
our
we're going to iterate through our items
which is now a list of tuples
so count item
and items
then print f
and bracket count
and we're going to give this three
spaces
uh what's in there oh that's what i was
doing
to really make this clear and then item
so what i'm doing here is
so now let's
let's get this going uh list
and
ah this needs to be indented
there we go
all right let me see
why this isn't working so we're
splitting our line
and we're going through
file.read.split.one
for count and item items
that should have enumerated
okay this
all right
and let me check
this right here what is the difference
between these two
let me uncomment this and figure out
oh aha so this needs to be
because i'm already reading the file
there we go
okay so now oh now we got a problem
check this out there's a new problem
right
i forgot about this this one so what
just happened
should be count
oh no i only have one parentheses here
i only have so here look
i just have this output to kind of get
the attention
of it's it's something that i did a long
time ago
i used to do a dot and then uh somebody
showed me a nice little parenthesis
to just have this sit here at the end to
just kind of clean it up and have your
have your eyes jump to it so i have this
space three
and going through now i could do a
parenthesis over here
but it just looks too busy i just like
this nice clean structure
of that one little parentheses to go hey
here's your place in your list here's
your number on the list
so we can have a point of reference now
here's this dilemma i just called list
and it put list in the list but i don't
want that
so we need to figure out
how to solve this
we'll deal with that in a minute because
i think that's further down
but we have got so we have
we have that going and we have this
printing
so now we've got to figure out how to
remove
how to remove
remove equals int
input then
enter number
to delete
now for the sake of uh
for the sake of saving a little bit of
time now
just like we learned that when we got
into entering our list
we got into that and it was just going
over and over and over and over again
so we need to figure and plan for a way
to get out of our deletion
right so enter number due
to delete or 0
to continue
and i'm already mixing and matching
all right so and i don't think i have
enough parentheses
there we go all right so that's
that's we're taking the input if
remove equals zero
break jump out
jump out and uh continue on
oops that's for next step sorry
i didn't do that
continue
sorry i ruined ruined our
edition because i realized only about a
year after this
i had a bug that i didn't even know
so continue
because you always have to be prepared
for the user
just just to have areas of
possibilities of mistakes so then else
is where it gets fine all right
so we're going to delete items
i'm going to remove
minus one
then now here's where it gets fun
okay are you ready
uh we're going to do another context
manager
because this is how we're going to
handle
where to go
item dot
as as file
and for item
in items because that variable is still
currently working file.right
then item
one
then we need to add so what we're doing
is we're going and deleting the item but
then we need to
because each item has a return put at
the end of it
right so then now we need to add
the return back
all right so let's let's see if i have
everything here because now we're going
to have a
new error we
solved the problem we solved another one
of them
but we have not air proofed this
to have let's just jump into it so list
and i need to click over list
all right
all right any questions right now
[Applause]
all right
now we need to solve
so let's get zero to continue
list then i want to delete
one then list
so it didn't quite go through so let's
let's look and see where i am
and what the issue is
all right so now i need to bring in
we need we need one more little tidbit
right here
because right now we got inner item and
they don't know what they don't know
about list
they don't really know what to do so we
need
we need to handle something right here
so
please print
and we're going to do this type
anytime
exit to quit
and list
to read
read and delete
and then one two three
close this out
all right so here we are oh
at any time press exit to quit or list
all right let's see where
where i am
seek zero
all right
all right because now
oops
so let's see where i am
list
apparently i cannot remember the bug to
get this off the list
right now so i'll need to work on that
but if i were to hit zero here
hit hit uh oh i think i got a comment
shopping list is missing a g
sharpening this is missing a g ooh uh
red line all right
okay uh let's go and solve this because
um my voice is very very uncomfortable
sorry
it was you fixed it okay all right cool
now
so we need to have an issue
of right here how to delete
and solve this dilemma because right now
uh i thought i've tested this multi time
so
i need to when we get done we will wrap
up our
uh we'll wrap this fix up this
this issue right here and i remember
having it vaguely
and all the tests i did this morning but
all right
we need to handle we need to have a try
and accept
right here and it needs to go
all right so it needs to go
right here so this is where
so while while true
while true try
so what i'm doing
i want you to think about this control
bracket
control bracket so the reason why i had
indent twice is because i gave two
headers
now this actually needs to be
down here so we'll copy
and the reason why it goes down here
because the reason so let let's look at
this
let's bring this here so we can see it
so the reason why this is failing
is this fails
once you hit enter and you want to have
your try block
wherever the possible failures are and
the reason why
you want to be in here you want this to
be going over and over and over again
that and then
if that is a zero they jump out of here
and come back up to here does that make
sense because
you want this loop to come through and
give them the error
and then send them back up here and have
the opportunity hey did you mean
did you mean to hit zero do you still
want to delete or do you want to go on
and continue on the list all right
so let's do this
okay so now i get boom boom boom boom
there we go and i'm in alignment with my
try and i have a value error
so i'm going to do accept
accept value
error so the value v and the e our
um our
r are capitalized so then
print what did i say because i think i
think i came up with something very
handy
if you don't
want to
delete please
enter 0. now i want you to think about
this
i'm doing a horrible job with my
quotation marks today
oh that was why that one is is because
i have you know what let's look at an
escape character
so while we're talking about escape
characters
so if i hit list
and then
and then i'm up here
to remember to delete
so then now
now this needs to be changed to break
because i'm inside this loop i need to
come back up to this loop
so then boom i'm back up to be able to
then
add and edit and i will
so we're about we're just a little over
an hour by like a minute so an hour
so yeah guys i really thought my voice
would be rested and i will use some tea
and honey but actually before we go
i realized that we had a dilemma
last time and it
alluded me to y
so there's my list and i know it's
on the tip of my tongue on the tip of my
fingers so all right
this is how you handle so i was talking
about no spaces between
files this is how you handle um
spaces between files you'd put it in
quotation marks
so it's free code
camp dot p y
so then it runs oops why not right
inside this
i just did this the other day
pre-code python
well i'm just not doing a very good job
today
i just did this earlier today so i guess
i have two things to clean up
for uh for now next week sorry exit
and that's also why you don't do
lowercase exit
so that's another keyword that python
has
but yes this is a great exercise and
like i said
oops and then continue on and then
exit so just a very little
handy experiment where you can learn
about
all these file objects and modes
and workflow because this is a
phenomenal one where you then have this
problem
and you have to go through and the
reason why this works is because i'm
escaping out
from this i'm saying hey
when i get rid of this it's stopping the
string right here
but now i'm escaping out of it and
saying no
i literally want this quotation mark
right here
i want that to stay because i have these
two so
i think that's what i was thinking today
sorry guys
um as always i really enjoy these
streams i really enjoy the interaction
i have a good time thanks for spending
your time with me you guys could go
anywhere i want to thank bo and quincy
for this wonderful opportunity to get to
share my knowledge and experience
because i really truly love
python very much i've been studying it
for
uh seven years now i guess i just passed
seven years and i just truly enjoy
sharing this and um the things that i've
had to fight through and learn
and even as you can see right here got a
got a bug that
i could have sworn had it solved and
then another one so i'll make notes
uh oh and we need to we're going to work
on pointers
and is and um id
and all of those things uh next week
so like you hear on my other channel
always guys please
leave any comments questions video
requests uh
i've gotten into a pretty good habit of
not closing this out all this
all this is going to be on github you
can go
and check that out and delete it and we
will
well i really hope you guys get
something out of this because i truly
love
teaching and love i'm constantly
learning the stuff that i'm working
the stuff that i'm working on i'm always
finding a newer and better way to do it
because about a year ago
like i said had a young young man i was
showing and he said well
how do we handle this if they if they
don't enter anything
i said that's a great question so we had
to change the whole workflow
but you have the tools to do it so as
always guys
thanks for watching and we will see you
guys next week
all right bye